c'était pour moi l'époque paisible des
jours heureux en ce temps là je mets les
fontaines les petits ruisseaux le gave
de pau qui poule est clair j'allais dans
les bois aussi ramasser des châtaignes
et cherchait des champignons
nous signale oui
béto
opel monsieur travaille sur ça me
rappelle d'abord mon enfance étant donné
que j'ai été à l'école ici et ensuite ça
me rappelle un peu plus tard quand j'ai
été instituteur adjoint
des fois quand vous voyez ces enfants
est-ce que vous retrouver l'enfant que
vous étiez longue
voyez maintenant rêver comme anti sont
habillés ils voyaient leur tablier est
varié tandis que nous nous avions
toujours le tablier noir établi et et
noir à cette époque la goutte au nez
derrière avec les trois boutons est lié
par une ceinture regarder et là des
bottes elle
mais nous nous avions simplement les
galoches d'autres points il y a autre
chose si j'avais pu constater qu'ils
avaient le ballon
nous n'en avions pas parce qu'il ne
fallait pas cassé les vitres et ce qui
me rappelle encore quelque chose quand
nous voulions jouer au bar et à ce
moment là
eh bien nous partions en nous tenant par
le court et et nous appelions qui veut
jouer le bar tu veux jouer au bar
il faut dire à ce moment là il faut tout
de même une considération générale
s'impose c'est l'oeuvre magnifique
scolaire de la troisième république
la troisième république a établi la
laïcité de l'état et enlever aux
congrégations le soin de former la
jeunesse et la pris ce soin pour elle
est admirablement dans chaque village de
france
une petite école ou même relativement
grande avec un instituteur et un
instituteur voué à sa tâche passionné
pour apprendre les éléments aux enfants
des paysans du village et l'école était
devenu un centre du village et
l'instituteur bientôt secrétaire de la
mairie dirigeait toute administration du
village et ses écoles ont fait les
enfants qui ont été les soldats de 14
quelle est l'ambiance parmi les jeunes
de leur âge c'était patriotique le bien
des instituteurs même si oui même chez
les instituteurs jeu femmes ms surtout
il dans votre cas vous avez aussi été
dans une école normale d'instituteurs
oui oui oui c'était la vie c'est les
filles mais les leçons de morale de
civisme c'est on appelait ça des leçons
de civisme de morale était donnée été
très suivi et écouté nous arriver en
oeuvre précise et nous rendrions me
replace en rend bien sûr nous
commencions tout de suite la leçon la
première leçon c'était de la morale pour
louis maurat le mardi mercredi
instruction civique vendredi moral il
samedi la lecture du samedi
ils ne purent moral
la morale est une science qui vous
enseigne faire le bien et à éviter le
mal étudié la morale c'est apprendre à
ce bien conduire et être raisonnable
pour apprendre à bien conduire il faut
se connaître soi même être attentif aux
bons conseils suivre l'exemple de nos
parents et de nous mettre et de tous
ceux qui avaient à l'époque en
séparation de la liesa
il y avait le ministre comme emile comme
comme avait dit voilà je ne supprime pas
les écolos libre mais celui ci pourra se
les payer seul et pena et alors il n'en
a créé le colonat hic gratuite et
obligatoire pour tout le passé moi j
étais à l'école mais j'en ai vu de
vonage était jamais allé à l'école qui
ne serait pas parler français
pourquoi ils n'avaient pas le moyen
n'est pas de s'acheter des vêtements
pour pour les garçons pour les envoyer à
l'école
et alors et n'y allez pas moi si j'avais
été à l'école sert elle était comme un
digital
oui si j'avais été à l'école mais je
vous avait été pourtant j'y suis c'est
mmo sévèrement on me faisait garder les
petits mamelles à la touche à mon père
était maçon de ce métier
alors ces boîtes qui gardait les petits
les autres mais vous saviez combien de
fois par semaine
enfin que je pouvais dimanche
monsieur le bâtonnier petit vous aviez à
l'école bouge pas beaucoup
pourquoi vous n'y allez pas beaucoup et
parce que j'avais dû avaler n'importe
quoi
et oui les vaches si vous y alliez
combien de fois par semaine à rodez x 1
3 avait pas mais oui aux penseurs à tous
les prêtres seul agent mince et des
hymnes aux et des fleurs ils ont lutté
pour l'humanité pour l'avenir d'une cité
fraternelle ils ont lutté pour
l'humanité pour l'avenir et pour la
liberté aux penseurs et xetra et c'est
là ce que nous avions appris c'est
quelque chose qui a marqué ça aussi et
qui à leurs créations sont la chanson et
jean macé c'était au moment mais spa où
il y avait peut-être séparation de
l'église et de l'état ou bien l'école
laïque et d'un côté l'école privée de
l'autre ça se passait en 1905 sa et la
différence a été grande après la loi de
combler la différence c'est la
différence a été là nous y pensions mais
c'est toujours pareil à rallier des
parents d'anissa des parents je veux
dire il y avait un frère qui était
répartie royalistes
à l'époque il y avait deux parties
eurent brisé le parti royaliste le parti
républicain
alors qu'ils étaient du parti
républicain qui avait adhéré au parti
républicain qui virent chaleur ne vais
pas en parler ni à dre et pourquoi il ne
faisait pas le virage a été séparée en
un à long terme m
il ya même eu des riches propriétaires
utilisés à leur métier
si vous envoyez à part à l'école laïque
geoffroy peur il y en a qui l'ont fait
mais tout de même ça c'est pas prévu
qu'il y avait un qui se sent obligée
izany no environ
regardant et grâce à l'école laïque robe
et c'est comme ça alors petit à petit
cette école b et neuf mois c'était
arrivé les curés était partie au régime
comme les autres et il s'arrangeait pas
le pire non seulement les biens des
transitions toujours suivi vous menez et
y en avoir qui sommes comblés release
notre île ne sont pas sages il existe et
ça lui sera toujours temps alors ça fait
comme aujourd'hui les jaunes du côté
catholique elle est rouge du côté en
isoler rouge c'était dans les radicaux
elle est jaune et ben c'était sur
youtube du pacte puisque le papa impôts
jour dont je crois est-ce que la
séparation de l'église et de l'état vous
a touché dans votre famille
moi ça ne m'a pas touché on sait qu'on
arrange ça nous a réjouis c'était une
famille républicaine
c'est à dire que vous à gt gt avec un
libertaire à cette époque là votre père
vous votre père avoue il était de quel
parti à mon père quand les gaules a
établi il avait dit moi j'en venais
l'école des gosses à l'école c'était un
républicain
on peut le dire maintenant il ne risque
plus rien d'autres peines
[Musique]